you mentioned early on like Psy it's
hard to grow what did you mean by that
because we're talking about scale might
change
uh there might be and we'll talk about
this too like there's a
emergent
there's certain things about these
neural networks that are emerging so
certain like performance we can see only
with scale and there's some kind of
threshold of scale so it why is it hard
to grow something like this meow Network
so the meow network is is not it's not
hard to grow if you retrain it yeah
what's hard is well we have now one
billion parameters
um we train them for a while we we spend
some amount of work towards building
these these weights that are an amazing
initial brain for doing these kind of
tasks we care about
could we reuse the weights and expand to
a larger brain and that is
extraordinarily hard but also exciting
from a research perspective and a
practical perspective point of view
right so there's this notion of
modularity in software engineering and
we're starting to see some examples and
work that leverages modularity in fact
if we go back one step from gato to a
work that I would say train much larger
much more capable Network called
Flamingo Flamingo did not deal with
actions but it definitely dealt with
images in in a in an interesting way
kind of akin to what agato did but
slightly different technique for
tokenizing but we don't need to go into
that detail but
what Flamingo also did which gather
didn't do and that just happens because
these projects you know they're they're
they're different you know it's it's a
bit of like the exploratory nature of
research which is great the research
Behind these projects is also modular
yes exactly um and it has to be right we
need we need to have creativity
um and sometimes you need to protect
pockets of you know people researchers
and so on but in humans yes okay and
also in particular researchers and maybe
even further you know deep mine or or
other side slabs and then yeah the
neural networks themselves so it's
modularity all the way down okay all the
way down so the way that we did
modularity very beautifully in Flamingo
is we took chinchilla which is a
language only model not an agent if we
think of actions being necessary for
agency so we took chinchilla we took the
weights of tinchilla and then we froze
them we said these don't change we train
them to be very good at predicting the
next word is a very good language model
state of the art at the time you release
it etc etc
we're gonna add a capability to C right
we are going to add the ability to see
to this language model so we're going to
attach
um small pieces of neural networks at
the right places in the model it's
almost like injecting
um the network with some weights and
some substructures in the ways in in a
good way right so you need the research
to say what is effective how do you add
this capability without destroying
others Etc so we created a small sub
Network
initialized not from random but actually
from
self-supervised learning that you know a
model that understands Vision
um in general and then we took data sets
that connect the two modalities vision
and language and then we froze the main
part the largest portion of the network
which was chinchilla that is 70 billion
parameters and then we added a few more
parameters on top trained from scratch
and then some others that were
pre-trained from like from with the
capacity to see like it was a it was not
tokenization in the way I described
forgotto but it's a similar idea
and then we train the whole system parts
of it were frozen parts of it were new
and all of a sudden we developed
Flamingo which is an amazing model that
is essentially I mean describing it is a
chatbot where you can also upload images
and start conversing about images
um but it's also kind of a dialogue
style
um uh chatbot so the input is images and
touch and the output is text exactly
um and how many parameters you said 70
billion 70 billion for chinchilla yeah
chin Chile is 70 billion and then the
ones we add on top which kind of almost
is almost like
um a way to overwrite its its little
activations so that when it sees Vision
it does kind of a correct computation of
what it's seeing mapping it back towards
so to speak
um that adds an extra 10 billion
parameters right so it's total 80
billion the largest one we released and
then you train it on a few data sets
that contain vision and language and
once you interact with the model you
start seeing that you can upload an
image and start sort of having a
dialogue about the image
um which is actually not something it's
it's very similar and Akin to what we
saw in language only this prompting
abilities that that it has you can teach
it in a new a new vision task right it
does things beyond the capabilities that
in theory the data sets
um provided in themselves but because it
leverages a lot of the language
knowledge acquired from chinchilla it
actually has this few shot learning
ability and these emerging abilities
that we didn't even measure once we were
developing the model but once developed
then as you play with the interface you
you can start seeing wow okay yeah it's
cool we can we can upload I think one of
the tweets talking about Twitter was
this image from Obama that is placing a
weight and and someone is kind of
waiting themselves and and it's kind of
a joke style image and it's notable
because I think Andre karpati a few
years ago said no computer vision system
can can understand the subtlety of this
joke in this image all the things that
go on and so what we try to do and it's
very anecdote anecdotally I mean this is
not a proof that we solved this issue
but it just shows that you can upload
now this image and start conversing with
the model trying to make out if it if it
gets that there's a joke
um because the person waiting themselves
don't see that doesn't see that someone
behind is making the weight higher and
so on so forth so it's a fascinating
capability
um and it comes from this key idea of
modularity where we took a frozen brain
and we just added a new capability so
the question is should we so in a way
you can see even from deepmind we have
Flamingo that these this moderate
approach
um and thus could leverage the scale a
bit more reasonably because we didn't
need to retrain a system from scratch
and the other on the other hand we had
gato which used the same data sets but
then he trained it from scratch right
and so I guess big question for the
community is
so we train from scratch or should we
Embrace modularity and this lies like
this goes back to modularity as a way to
grow but reuse seems like natural and it
was very effective certainly the next
question is if you go the way of
modularity
is there a systematic way of freezing
weights and joining different modalities
across
you know not just two or three or four
networks but hundreds of networks from
all different kinds of places maybe open
source Network that looks at weather
patterns and you shove that in somehow
and then you have networks that uh I
don't know do all kinds of play
Starcraft and play all the other video
games and they you can keep adding them
in without significant effort like that
maybe the effort scales linearly or
something like that as opposed to like
the more Network you add the more you
have to worry about the instabilities
created yeah so that that vision is
beautiful I think
um there's still the question about
within single modalities like chinchilla
was reused but now if we train a next
iteration of language models are we
going to use chinchilla or no yeah how
do you swap out right so there's there's
still big questions but that idea is
actually really akin to software
engineering which we're not
re-implementing you know libraries from
scratch we're reusing and then building
ever more amazing things including
neural networks with software that we're
using so I think this idea of modularity
I like it I think it's here to stay and
that's also why I mentioned it's just
the beginning not the end